Bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovissimo video io sono Favij
sono vestito a tema natalizio perché
manca ancora un sacco di Natale ma chi
se ne frega era felpa natalizia che ho e
c'ho freddo Ok c'ho freddo Quindi metto
questo Ciao Katia ragazzi su godzim
wainer nel prossimo voglio vedere se
riesco a fare
nel prossimo voglio vedere se riesco a
fare qualcosa Eh Col multiplayer visto
che hanno aggiunto il multiplayer però
per adesso Salve
Arrivederci vedo che è sempre più strana
questa vedo che è sempre più strano
questo gioco lui la Madonna Addirittura
hanno programmato le macchine per far
manovra Cioè ma quanto ho fatto volevo
vedere ragazzi visto che siamo arrivati
alla fine della mappa grazie grazie
Siamo arrivati alla fine della mappa se
riesco a Innanzitutto trovare la torre
così ecco almeno Allora ragazzi Fermi
tutti che c'è un cerchio infuocato lo
vedo da qua Prova a vedere se riesco ad
entrarci raga c'è un cannone Nice
levatevi che devo spararmi Togliti Come
si è si salta Si può entrare nel cerchio
ci provo
Mamma mia che scarso ma proprio in alto
Let's go
cioè al secondo tentativo non è ma vuol
dire proprio che ho passato la mia vita
su giochi di merda vuoi provare a salire
su un paio di rampe perché ancora li
rampe non fate veramente poche c'è
quella lì che la vedo bella carica
attenzione
Let's go
Comunque sto gioco è un po' esagerato eh
non so
Ma dove sta [ __ ] Thor Ah lassù
Ragazzi ma che cazzo sta succedendo Ma
non so come commentare sta roba raga c'è
una roba
Ma basta ma perché sto gioco non ha un
senso devo trovare un modo per salire
sul palazzo perché sennò non riesco a
raggiungere la torre per sincronizzarmi
Ecco c'ho la scala Let's go
ce l'ho fatta
vamos Eccola Minchia introvabile sta
roba Oh allora Jerry Go ci siamo ragazzi
ho trovato Ci ho messo una vita però
effettivamente ci siamo io la mia
melanzanina
lancio anche i fuochi per festeggiare
già che ci siamo credo di aver trovato
Qua ci sono macchine da corsa Vai
bellissimo Grazie ragazzi Non lo so
Madonna Questa va velocissimo Cosplay
convention Aspe che c'è il cosplay Cos'è
un Frisbee è un Pikachu molto
indispettito dalla vita Eh ragazzi
Ditemi se non è il Goku più depresso
della storia Guarda che faccia
è terribile Eh vabbè ma eh ho lanciato
lo scudo cioè finché non lo ripiglio
continua a rimbalzare sta cosa è geniale
sembra un po' la scia di Kratos
va bene così Continua a sbloccarmi roba
epiche seguace della moda a cambio i
vestiti alla gente sto male ma cosa sono
un outlet ambulante ragazzi Vabbè allora
ragazzi porca [ __ ]
Silent Hill vediamo
mi fa anche entrare corridoio horror
Ok ok
Ah questo è PT No vabbè ragazzi
incredibile hanno rifatto Pitti adesso
si ricrea di nuovo
va bene cioè ci sono sempre più foto di
sto tizio ma tra l'altro Ragazzi io è
una cosa io non l'ho mai giocato Pitti
Tra l'altro io ho visto solo dei
Gameplay perché l'hanno tolto troppo in
fretta Non ho mai fatto in tempo Ditemi
voi se lo devo giocare su got Simulator
sto gioco Porco demonio si è chiusa la
porta
si è riaperta la porta mi pigli per il
culo
Grazie Mi fate capire dove dobbiamo
arrivare con sta cosa che non è non l'ho
giocato Pitti non so se devo fare Salve
Salve Oh la Madonna questo è
effettivamente molto Creepy
a posto Si è accesa una luce rossa
attenzione
giorno Guarda non so se è più horror Il
mio culo va bene porca [ __ ] ancora le
nonne testa di culo adesso c'ho il
contrattacco Nell'altro video non ce
l'avevo questo posso farmi valere c'è il
bagno adesso di regola dovrebbe spuntare
qualcosa C'è un tizio nudo nel cesso
si è aperta la
sono uscito
sono ancora in vita completa Ma cos'è mi
ha dato una roba da un lenzuolo va bene
cercando di cambiare zona Non so se si
capisce è questo è il trasporto veloce
veloce per modo di dire volevo capire un
attimo se effettivamente il tornado
quello che continua a vedere in
lontananza Se funziona ancora Perché io
cioè se ci passo vicino mi risucchia
perché sta andando in giro per la mappa
da quando l'ho attivato Ma sta roba è
assurda arrivo
Madonna raga Ci ho messo una pi Guarda
dove sei na ficcato Cioè nella dove c'è
la fontana del polpo Eh vabbè Mi sembra
un po' eccessivo si sta tirando via
anche le balle aiuto
Aiuto sto trombando un trattore in aria
tutto Tutto bene Tutto a posto
effettivamente un casino
vabbè cioè nel senso di tutto però
almeno abbiamo avuto la riprova che
funziona Cioè nel senso sta fare vai in
giro a far casini da quando l'ho
attivato pazzesca sta roba No ragazzi
cioè fanno yoga qua non so con che
criterio Tra l'altro salvezza
e questa è la mia posa da meditazione
ragazzi potresti anche dire che un umano
ha quattro gambe non siamo praticamente
capre che camminano sulle zampe È vero È
vero È vero sono ragionamenti validi
questi voglio solo un po' di erba No
vabbè Fratè Questa è una cosa che non si
può l'unica cosa che conta sono io ho
sbloccato un cerchio Alchemico cos'è il
potere del Loto per trascendere e
ricevere l'illuminazione cliccando cose
non ho capito
cambia colore il cielo Ma per quale
motivo Vabbè ho una lingua potentissima
che potrebbe essere fuorviante sto
discorso però no scusa
Ma te la cavi benissimo lo stesso nuovi
vicini amichevoli Ma è un robot questo
ho tagliato darla Porca [ __ ]
mi hanno sono nero è un attacco di robot
Porco demonio non avevo capito erano
tutti qua per provare a uccidermi E non
lo sapevo Aiuto aiuto entra la macchina
veloce
Porca vacca investiti
a Terminator sto gioco Ma cos'è dei
robot camuffati da esseri umani nuovi in
Cina amichevoli Hasta la vista
casalinghe era era un'associazione di
robot sotto copertura cioè una roba del
genere ho mai vista ragazzi cos'è faccia
da Nancy adesso sono Nancy ritorno anche
tu sei una Nancy Ahia Porco demonio non
sei Nancy però posso sparare dei laser
un sushi giorno Fate all you can eat qua
lo chiedo per un amico ah sì proprio mi
ha risposto sul serio pizza sicuramente
molto meglio della pizza che fanno in
America normale perché vi assicuro che
ecco il confronto sta foto che state
vedendo è Gourmet Vorrei vedere avete il
menù Ecco cioè Grazie marinara
capricciosa e il Tonia quattro ostaggi
quattro ostaggi per una quattro ostaggi
non posso averla Vabbè cosa
Salve Ti ho visto che si sia nascosto
Cioè ma che perché vi nascondete
necessità perché c'è gentili cestini
Perché siete nei cestini cosa succede
c'è ancora qualcuno ce n'è un altro
sopra la roulette la roulotte Sorry la
roulotte russa è stata una bellissima
partita a goat Simulator nel prossimo
episodio voglio provare se riesco a
Ma se la prendo che succede
prossimo episodio ragazzi voglio provare
a vedere se riesco a giocare in
multiplayer perché effettivamente il
multiplayer È una parte che ancora mi è
totalmente sconosciuta Proverò a vedere
se riesco a giocare con un ospite
speciale ragazzi con chi volete che
giochi in multiplayer di vetro fatemelo
sapere Ci vediamo ragazzi al prossimo
episodio di Grossi Simulator corso sui
ragazzi se vi è piaciuto lasciate un
commento e un mi piace anche per i
social quindi da te in descrizione Se
non siete ancora iscritti iscrivetevi e
noi ci vediamo come sempre ad un
prossimo video bella ragazzi
[Musica]